hello guys my name is a channel welcome
to episode 107 of game programming so
today we're gonna talk about fonts and
text rendering onto the screen because
we've just made out debug class last
time here it is right over here and we
were able to draw rectangles on the
screen if I just launch our game you
guys will be able to say that right over
here
it's our awesome rectangle great so now
let's talk about text because we're
gonna need to be able to render text
under the screen for a variety of
reasons for example let's just say we
want to know what an item name is or we
want to make a menu
pretty much anything like really that
headwords should be probably rendered by
itself so in other words we could just
obviously make an image with the name
and just put it up as just a sprite but
for some dynamic elements such as maybe
like an FPS counter actually on the
screen or something that like you know
what like a stat right for example the
speed of our character or the attack
strength that stuff is we can't just put
up about 10,000 images of every possible
combination of numbers and then just
kind of deal with that we want a way to
be able to easily rent a text so in
other words our goal here is to
basically and ignore the fact that I'm
in the debug class all right now but we
basically should be able to go something
like you know font render hello out like
position 5 X 10 Y and then maybe like a
font size of 8 or 9 you know something
like that right that's how easy it
should be okay so that's what we're
gonna we're basically going to focus on
for the next two episodes so this
episode we're going to talk about
actually creating the font sheet in the
next episode which I'm actually gonna
probably upload later today hopefully
there we're gonna talk about actually
integrating that into our code and being
able to make it a fun class and call
that stuff so let's actually make a
phone class right away so you know
graphics folder here I'm gonna go right
click on that and you and then class
again an in class want to probably call
it font right and call text you can call
whatever you want I think font is a good
name there because we're probably gonna
because ok we'll actually do make a
class called font because I think
there's gonna be multiple fonts and we
want to kind of keep it I guess more or
less like this ok great sir
let's go ahead and and basically outline
what this cloths gonna do okay and how
this entire thing is gonna work I'm
wishing I had a better way to show this
but okay let's have him paint on there
here okay so basically the idea is we've
got a font sheet which might be um just
for the sake of this maybe like two
hundred forty by like I don't know forty
eight this might be the size of our
about font sheet and if we make this
something like just a grid so you guys
can see what I mean
so maybe um we can't make it wait as we
can okay so 24 four you know a lot of
and this is huge obviously but let's
just say we've got this right each one
of these cells right this is a sprite
sheet by the way each one of these cells
will have their own letter okay so what
we need to do is we need to load that
into a game using our sprite sheet class
that's why I had it open and extract
individual sprites from that we could
have every letter of the alphabet every
number of the alphabet every lowercase
letter and symbol or whatever in its own
sprite and load them all individually as
files that's going to be really really
slow and just unnecessary it's better to
load them all as one in one spreadsheet
file so to do that we're just gonna lay
out it's called a font sheet basic or a
bitmap font sheet or something like that
I did varies from depending on what kind
of person you are I just call them for
sure it's okay now I'm character sheets
is probably another white but the proper
at the point is every single character
that we ever want to use we need to map
out okay and then in the code we're
gonna be able to grab the appropriate
character when we do call something like
font up you know our font done whatever
we had before their ID font on render
hello right when we call hello it's
gonna be able to grab uppercase H
uppercase lowercase e ll or etc right
cool so to do that we need a way to
first of all load that spreadsheet in
not going to talk too much about that
today or right now in episode 117
website 109 we'll cover that in much
greater detail but some essentially what
we need to do is make a a sprite sheet
here now we could make it over here I'm
not going to because this is great for
like tiles and whatever but I think the
font should have its own sprite sheet
show
make sure it's static okay we don't want
to have a new one of these with every
instance so private static sprite shade
and then what we'll do is we'll call it
like font for now right we
everything on one font will equal new
sprite sheet again now we've got a bunch
of constructors here we've got the
strength path in size and being with
height and then we've got this which is
what we want okay well first of all
remember we have to actually load in the
font sheet the actual the actual like
shade okay so I'm actually gonna make a
folder in our game directory we've got
this rain folder of course we've got
resources and then we've got levels
textures I'm actually gonna make another
folder called fonts okay and inside
fonts this is where our actual font
trade is gonna lie so I'm gonna make I'm
gonna make it so the path will be um you
know just like fonts slash the wheat we
need a forward slash in front of that
though yes we do okay so because it's
all relative to the class to the jar
file so fonts slash I don't know what
I'll call this maybe like what let's
just make an Arial font slopes call it
Arial dot PNG right and you can make
whatever font you want you can actually
make your own fonts so you can actually
just draw draw like pixel art or
whatever if you want a really low res
font so we might do something like that
but um just for now this will do and
then the size okay does it so the size
of each character probably around I mean
remember our game is scaled up by a
significant I think it's like three or
something let's check this out what's
the is it just called game yeah yeah our
scale is three so remember that so maybe
like um six ain't the best way to do
this by the way the best way to check
out sizes is we've got this rectangle
here which is nice so what basically if
I just go to play a class for example I
think that's where we're rendering the
rectangle isn't it okay search file dip
bar basically that'll search the entire
um here it is I guess it's ensure okay
so we're drawing this rectangle let's um
let's draw it I'll set the tracking to
false basically the width and height
let's make it like 32 by 32 all right
and then this stuff will make it maybe
like I don't know fifty fifty does it
matter
alright let's draw that okay so that
that's how big if we make our font 32 by
32 each character that's how big it's
gonna look that's huge right I might
want to do something a bit smaller like
16 by 16 let's see what that looks like
it's good to have it as a power of two
necessary they were not doing with like
OpenGL textures or anything so it
doesn't need to be a power to but it can
be so that's the size of one tile you
know what let's stick with that right
because that sixteen by sixteen is
clearly the size of one tile here
so I think that's a good size for a
phone again so um I'm just gonna get rid
of this debug door a rectangle call
altogether great
so in font we've got this stuff's we'll
make it our sixteen right because
remember it will get scaled up sixteen
times three of course is 48 so it'll be
basically for the airport for you a true
pixels on our screen wonderful when we
make a font okay we need to actually um
okay well this is one spreadsheet right
but the idea is we want to create
another sub spreadsheet there's an
episode on that if you guys didn't catch
that
so um font characters alright so if we
make a new sprite sheet and you know
from the existing one which is font okay
we actually get a interesting
constructed here let me just see if I
can find that constructor here we go so
we have sheet shape right so in other
words I'll be fond we've got the x and y
okay and I'm trying to remember this
stuff X&Y what on earth could that mean
so this is why it's important to
document you carrot with an height of H
thing wait a minute is this even gonna
do what I want it to give me a sec guys
just go check out my code yeah what does
this do again so what do we use it for
are we created three our crops the
sprite sheet doesn't it individually
alright that's not gonna cut it because
we need to actually extract sprites we
haven't done that haven't we okay we're
gonna do that next episode okay because
as I said all the rendering and
extraction stuff will up next episode so
what we need to do and I'm actually
going to put a to do is extract sheet
cells into individual sprites alright
really important then we can probably
clear this from memory or at least hope
that Java garbage does that itself okay
so public font you know we'll take in it
doesn't matter what we'll take in right
right now yeah we'll put in like the
back end functionality first next
episode and then well um we'll talk
about this stuff so this is it
really been nine minutes are you kidding
me right now maybe that's wrong no one
has been oh my good okay so I want to
get on with this I'm gonna use Photoshop
for this okay so first I'm on the first
thing I want to do and I say that that's
just as a plot paint on that but um I'll
tell you why in a minute
so let's make a new canvas size so we
decided 16 right I'm gonna bring out a
calculator here so 16 right we have how
many letters in the alphabet okay we've
got 26 so 13 would give us half of that
we don't want to make the font sheet too
long otherwise it'd be hard to read by
humans not by technology but let's just
say so we 16 times maybe if width of 13
actual characters right so that gives us
208 okay so now we'll put the canvas
size to be 208 wide now the height on
the other hand how many of them do we
want so we want letters A through Z
capital lowercase that's already for
right that's already for and I'll be
time 16 eventually but for then we also
want numbers and symbols so like symbols
like at the you know . comma explanation
mark question mark that stuff and
numbers of course 0 through 9 someone
I'd probably call it another two rows
for that because I don't think one will
be no it could be I'm just thinking ya
know I think it will be okay so I'm
we'll call it six right so 6 times 16 96
okay okay so the reason I'm using let's
just clips I'm gonna clear this entire
thing the reason I'm using paired on
that for this is because I like
paint.net in the grid thing it has so 16
size here hit OK and then it actually
makes a nice grade for us really easy to
do it harder to do in Photoshop alright
so I want to save this into our arm
let's see I was this oh this is my other
this is um the channel engine and stuff
isn't it this is if you guys haven't
been watching the Cherno engine um live
streams by the way you guys are missing
out there's a video on my channel about
that go watch that and also check out
the actual livestream and twitch.tv for
slash that sure know now what am i doing
what am i doing I now go into throng
workspace over and over again
game programming okay here we go so rain
we've got the the resources file here
we've got phones so I'm going to save it
as Ariel detente because there it's
gonna call it okay
so why am I not just pulling out the
font here this is an opportunity for you
guys to make your own fonts by the way
what you can do is um one thing I'm
probably going to do quickly actually is
redo this grid where there are different
colors so there's gonna be a pink color
magenta color for well the full pink
color will be transparent right so
that's one and then the other color
gonna use is choose probably 7f I just
like it right it's a nice gradient it's
just a darker purple though we're just
gonna use that for the borders we will
take the borders away when we actually
when we actually render it again sorry
when we actually like export it out
properly okay
the borders are just now to help to help
us make sure that everything is in D
size so let's go ahead and generate a
grid now
and that's actually perfect so there we
go right so now we've got a grid this
stuff looks pretty good to me I'm gonna
save that right now you guys could go
ahead and let's just say it pick a color
black here you guys could definitely go
definitely go ahead and make your own
characters here so if I took color where
is the color gone did I just close that
I am just yeah I did okay so let's just
have this to black quickly what I could
do is I could just draw like the letter
I don't know the letter A here now I'm
obviously rushing here I'm not that bad
but let's just say you know you could
draw like the letter A here and and and
you know and make your own basically
make your own font stuff doing that okay
and that that would work out pretty good
and depending on what kind of look
you're going for it could actually be
pretty much perfect for your game but
some we're actually gonna use a real
font just because I'm not gonna waste
you got your guys time making all these
characters individually so that is the
that's the deal right but you can do
this yourself and it could look really
cool because it's sixteen by sixteen is
rather low resolution so I'm actually
not even sure how this will work out but
some I'll let's see if it will so let's
open that so where is it Ariel PNG I'm
just gonna drag that in
okay there it is double-click on this
background look what did you guys how to
use Photoshop I don't know how to use
Photoshop myself very well of an After
Effects person as you know that's why I
use it for um we could use After Effects
for this no I I'm not gonna be that
silly but that's why I use alter effects
of like album Darren for making this
price and stuff but um let's go ahead
and I yeah so text alright let's make
the phone like I don't know eight or
something all that that seems good
letter a okay now you see you get this
anti-aliasing here right that's the
computer desperately all that I'll
Photoshop desperately trying to make
sense of why we're doing stuff that
small you can actually get rid of
anti-aliasing if you see this strong
that's like the are theorizing put this
tune on and it will you can see it's
gotten rid of that completely little
sharp now so that's the idea you want to
have that off let's try make this as big
as we can here that's a good site for
teens actually a good size okay you
would have thought okay so remember
these borders are going to go away these
borders are not part of this crap okay
in fact we're gonna take it all this
silhouette all the all of this away and
then just put in the pink background so
this stuff these borders do not matter
you can put stuff like that that's fine
now you cannot put stuff like that
because that would be entering the next
tile okay so one tile okay or one sprite
goes from here from zero zero down to
here okay I know it's a bit hard to say
but there we go so it does it includes
the top and the left border alright
great
this stuff is going to take a while but
some because I like doing this stuff in
front of you guys I'm going to do it in
front of you so all I'm doing here is
I'm I'm hitting ctrl J I'm selecting the
layers hitting ctrl J and then if I hold
shift and drag like any other normal
program I think it will um he'll just
drag it along one axis okay so we're
just gonna do this a ton until we get
enough characters here so you can see
that they're looking pretty decent I
mean you know when you're making a game
that is that low res it's just gonna
look a low res alright but that's
alright because that's kind of in
compliance with the wood
I don't know the same little feeling of
the game so I'm gonna grab all this ctrl
J and then just drag it down there oh
yeah all right so now we have the
process of changing these A's into
actual actually what we want so to do
that I'm just gonna go ahead and zoom in
there so a copy okay
um grab that turns out to a bit change
that to a okay never learn how to do
this quickly so safe
I'm actually gonna align them later all
right so I'm not gonna line all of them
now I'm just doing this roughly so see
um was my typing tool D a f j anyway you
guys get the point right I'm not gonna
do this all in front of you because I
would bore you to death but the idea is
you keep changing I even learned the
show puzzle show up that come on okay I
don't have time to wait for you to hover
off okay H I l am alright here we have a
bit of a problem where we don't know
where to align it to the left or the
right side I'd recommend you guys align
it to the left side okay so keep it on
the left side give it as much the left
as possible if you have to choose like
this I for example I don't know what
it's doing but let's the line out a bit
better so in other words yeah keep it
more towards because remember that that
purple border is actually part of this
right so yes okay that looks pretty good
there let's move down alright so now
we've got two letters the W is way too
big so let's talk about out for a minute
you can see it's way too big we could
make the font smaller or we could just
like it's very wide so what I'm gonna do
is actually if I right-click on that I
know you guys won't see it most of this
but if I there's like a rasterized type
thing and say it yeah I rasterize are
the best to just convert them into
pixels ctrl T on that baby and then just
shrink it like that okay and that looks
pretty good
alright and then it'll do a bunch of
bloody anti-aliasing so I just say put
that somehow and you should be swayed to
go how do I disable that
how about no interpolation bro can I
stop it from there we go alright so
there we go
right that is how you do that I know
that's trailing off a bit but that's a
right it's a W no one cares about values
right that looks pretty good
okay and is that my bed fit too anyway
you guys can play around with that make
it whatever you want I'm going for the
next episode I'm actually gonna
duplicate this do with lowercase
characters and other general characters
such as exciting marks you know.com is
whatever apostrophes quotation marks
whatever but save that to take control s
I you might want to save it as a
Photoshop file if you're using Photoshop
just because it'll say well these layers
intact because otherwise if you wear too
wet okay let's come up with a dialog box
I might Alamo number so yeah whatever
okay and then file save as that PNG file
right now that's pretty much done except
the fact that it's not because um mmm
it's still got the the background so to
get rid of the background you just you
can just make it literally just make a
new layer here okay
drag it all the way down to the very
bottom you might want to group these
number I might do that right now
actually after I drag all this stuff so
if you select all of the layers that are
letters you can you can probably create
some kind of folder for them we might do
that separately how do you create
folders in first okay here we go so
folder or group I want to call that
letters maybe like Appa case letters you
can make a group for every kind of type
of character and drag this up into
letters here we go and then you can just
minimize that alright great so this
layer one what I'm do I'm just gonna
hide all without letters here and this
thing so I'm just gonna grab the paint
bucket tool here which is actually
hiding behind the gradient tool by the
way and good thing I remember that and
then I'm gonna set the color of course
to be FF 0 0 FF alright and then just
click OK that's it
and if you bring up all letters you can
see they have no borders fantastic so
save that and set that as a PNG and you
should be good to go
now I'm gonna what has popped up now in
our code next time
I hope you guys enjoyed this very long
and seriously long episode of games
running for we did but um we're gonna
talk about extracting sheep cell and to
individual sprites that might actually
take up a good ten minutes so I might
split this up into a third episode for
where we actually make our font class
properly because I thought we already
had this functionality but we do not
okay anyway guys hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of game programming if you
did please hit that like button it is
just below it's cool to hit that that's
what the cool kids are doing and I'll
see you guys next episode which should
be letter today
okay goodbye
you